[Musique]
le nouvel entamoul a été célébré par le
Département ce vendredi 28 avril au
Palais de la source décoré aux couleurs
de l'Inde
la Réunion c'est une réunion de toutes
les origines et la communauté tamoul
participent activement au Bien Vivre
ensemble au développement de la réunion
à la promotion de nos cultures
c'est pour cela que le département
chaque année accueille des associations
de la communauté taboule de la Réunion
et cette année en particulier parce
qu'il y a tant de bouleversement dans le
monde
et à cette violence
un
monde de célébrant ce nouvel entamole et
je dis
réunionnaise Réunionnais d'origine
indienne bonne année bonne année à
toutes 5124
[Musique]
le baltamoul était mise à l'honneur
cette année un art inscrit au patrimoine
culturel immatériel depuis décembre 2022
[Musique]
de danser et des chanteuses histoires en
même temps ou
impatiente pas ce message comme souvent
nous fait autant que la première et là
c'est un autre façon d'esprit de
l'histoire-gontier dans théâtre une
invité de marque était présente
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité à souligner la richesse du
vivre ensemble réunionnais
ce moment il se veut avant tout
convivial un moment du vivre ensemble
qui je dois le dire c'est du bien car il
permet à tous quel que soit notre
communauté notre religion nos
confessions nos convictions de nos
retrouver de nous réunir vous êtes le
tissu économique vous êtes le tissu
artisanal on a vu vous êtes le tissu
associatif et vous êtes un ciment fort
de notre diversité culturelle française
et singulièrement réunionnaise je vous
remercie
foutant de vache tout calme
5124 bonne année
500024 à vous tous
et j'arrive festive animée par divers
ateliers spectacles de danse
[Musique]